I will show you I'll show you exactly
what it looks like this is going to be
well different and this actually would
directly relate to what we're gonna do
probably will depends how I go prove one
more period to what's this thing will
look like well I know it has a I mean
keep in mind these are the same these
are the same polynomial right so I have
a room at home at the zero x equals zero
is n equals 0 if you like now this is
route but I don't have any other routes
for this food right no other words so
what else could I use to work out like
the shape of this yes yeah I can I could
do I could differentiate if I like I
mean there are other tools like ease but
why not differentiate so if I if I
differentiate this guy X cubed plus X
what do I get 3 x squared plus 1 ok now
why is this useful at this point swing
fancy ok so you're starting to get into
our next topic right but I will I will
quickly mention it's fine it's ok when
this thing equals 0
I'll have less you I'll have the graph
stopping it'll just stop because
gradient of 0 means I have what does
that mean about the tangent where the
grade is 0 it means it's horizontal
right because that's what gradient 0
means ok now tell me remember all of
this is like real numbers right x and y
I'm graphing y versus X when's that
thing equal to 0 3 x squared plus 1 it's
never equal to 0 is it in the real
number field it's never because the
smallest x squared could possibly be is
0 right so the smallest your gradient
can possibly be is 0 plus 1 which is 1
okay by the way where does that take
place at x equals 0 the gradient is 1 so
that means I know what's happening here
a gradient of 1 is something like a 45
degree angle ok now keep in mind
you've just told me the gradient will
never become zero right um as I get
bigger and bigger X as I put bigger
numbers in here what's happening to the
gradient it's just getting bigger it's
just getting steeper and steeper forever
right like this what if I put in
negative numbers it's going to get all
right now because I'm squaring it's also
gonna get I'm gonna say oh it's steeper
right that's a little more descriptive
so as I get further this way my grading
is still getting steeper as they press
tape up somewhat like this that's it boy
yes it's no it's positively [ __ ]
because left to right I'm still climbing
right so another way of saying this is
because the gradient is always positive
this is a strictly increasing function
increases forever it never stops getting
higher
now this is the graph right you will
notice I only have one root on here
because all of these are real numbers so
there's my one real root okay I can't
really do anything with this on this
graph because there are no imaginary
numbers on this graph we'll get to them
but my important thing is this is a
factorization and just because we can do
this that doesn't mean we leave this
behind
because as I've demonstrated yeah we've
um we said that the definition of a
complex number is a real part and an
imaginary part but importantly the X and
the y they're real numbers okay so we
don't now that we know what complex
numbers are we're still going to
sometimes limit ourselves to real
numbers okay so this is still a useful
and meaningful process even though we
can go past it if we so choose so this
is a linear factorization okay and it's
only possible because we know a complex
numbers are off does anyone any
questions on that quickly
I might just quickly do one more example
cuz um because ma asked me yesterday
which is this question here I won't
finish it but I'll just start you off
this is this is the polynomial they give
you okay now
how do we go about factorizing this
thing now the great thing about this is
it's even worse than this one in that at
least with this in the real numbers you
can get somewhere in this you're already
stuck you take out your factor of 2 plus
said plus 2 and then you look at that
you're like oh yeah oh yeah that pair of
numbers that add to 1 and multiply it to
those numbers don't exist at least they
don't exist in the real field right so
that's why we must appeal to the complex
numbers ok so you got two choices you've
got two choices you can complete the
square to deal with this we deal with
them when you've got irrational roots
completing the squares the first method
we use or if you want to be a little
lazier you can just go straight to the
quadratic formula okay so for instance
you could say is n equals minus 1 B plus
or minus the square root of b squared
minus 4ac so far so good all over too
bad ok now I'm not going to go any
further you can go ahead and solve this
but you can immediately see there's your
negative number into the square root so
that guy there this is just going to
become the square root of 7i you take
out that negative one so there are your
complex numbers in the root once you get
two solutions out here the solutions are
not the factorization the solutions are
not the factorization for instance if I
had a quadratic and you know the one I'm
thinking you're good morning where the
on where the solutions are these two
right if you were to stall to get the
solutions it's not the factorization
what's the factorization hasn't related
to decisions yeah me too yeah
in other words what it actually is is X
take away one solution and X take away
beyond the solution right so once you
arrive in your complex roots right
you're going to go X minus one of them
and then X minus the other and there are
your two linear factors okay does that
make sense you're happy yes okay very
much depends I think some people are
more comes with one versus the other
you do need to have both so you know if
if the reason you're going to the
quadratic formula is because you hate
completing the square and you're not
very good at it you maybe need some
practice completing the square but
horses horses